I was born the same week that NASA was
founded the same week and so NASA and I
are the same age we we feel each other's
pains when NASA looks at Neil it says
Neil I'm your father here's what I want
to do it with your permission I want to
end I'm gonna take a little more time
here of your time with your permission a
few days ago I posted a birthday letter
to NASA an open letter to NASA I want to
read that letter to you as we end this
evening with your permission
okay dear NASA happy birthday
perhaps you don't know but we're the
same age in the first week of October
1958 you were born of the National
Aeronautics and Space act as a civilian
Space Agency well I was born of my
mother in the East Bronx don't lie to me
there ain't that many people from the
Bronx here in this room right now
so the year-long celebration of our
shared 60th anniversary provides me a
unique occasion to reflect on our past
present and future I was three years old
when John Glenn first orbited earth I
was seven when you lost astronauts
Grissom Chaffee and white in that tragic
fire of their Apollo 1 capsule on the
launch of had I was 10 when you launched
Armstrong and Aldrin when you landed
Armstrong and Aldrin on the moon and I
was 14 when you stopped going to the
moon altogether over that time I was
excited for you and for America but the
vicarious thrill of the journey so
prevalent in the hearts and minds of
others was absent from my emotions I was
obviously too young to be an astronaut
but I also knew that my skin color was
much too dark for you to picture me as
part of this epic adventure not only
that even though you are a civilian
agency your most celebrated astronauts
were military pilots at a time when war
was becoming less and less popular
during the 1960s the civil rights
movement was more real to me than it
surely was to you in fact it took a
directive from Vice President Johnson in
1963 to force you to hire black
engineers at your prestigious Marshall
Space Flight Center in Huntsville
Alabama
I found the correspondence in your
archive do you remember James Webb then
head of NASA wrote to German rocket
pioneer Wernher von Braun who headed the
center and who was the chief engineer of
the entire manned space program the
letter boldly and bluntly directs von
Braun to address the quote lack of equal
employment opportunity for Negroes in
the region and to collaborate with area
colleges Alabama A&M
at Tuskegee Institute to identify train
and recruit qualified Negro engineers
into the NASA Huntsville family in 1964
you and I had not yet turned six
when I saw picketers outside the newly
built apartment complex of our choice in
the Riverdale section of the Bronx they
were protesting to prevent Negro
families mine included from moving there
I was glad their effort failed these
buildings were called perhaps
prophetically the Sky View Apartments on
whose roof 22 stories over the Bronx I
would later train my telescope on the
universe my father was active in the
civil rights movement working under New
York City's mayor Lindsay to create job
opportunities for youth in the ghetto as
the inner city was called back then year
after year the forces operating against
this effort were huge poor schools bad
teachers meager resources abject racism
and assassinated leaders so while you
are celebrating your monthly advances in
space exploration from Mercury to Gemini
to Apollo
I was watching America to all it could
to marginalise who I was and what I
wanted to become in life I look to you
for guidance for a vision statement that
I could adapt that would fuel my
ambitions but you weren't there for me
of course I shouldn't blame you for
society's woes your conduct was a
symptom of America's habits not a cause
I knew this but you should nonetheless
know that among my colleagues I'm the
only one in my generation who became an
astrophysicist in spite of your
achievements in space rather than
because of them for my inspirations
instead turn to libraries remaindered
books on the cosmos
from bookstores my rooftop telescope and
the Hayden Planetarium
after some fits and starts through my
years in school we're becoming an
astrophysicist seemed at times to be the
path of most resistance through an
unwelcoming society I became a
professional astrophysicist I became a
scientist over the decades that followed
you've come a long way whoever does not
yet recognize the value of this
adventure to our nation's future soon
will as the rest of the development and
developing world passes us by in every
measure of technological leadership and
strength not only that these days if you
look much more like America from your
senior level managers to your most
decorated astronauts congratulations you
now belong to the entire citizenry
examples of this abound but I especially
remember when the public took ownership
of the Hubble telescope your most
beloved unmanned mission they all spoke
loudly back in the 2004 ultimately
reversing the threat that the telescope
might not be serviced a fourth time
extending its life for another decade
Hubble's transcended images of the
cosmos had spoken to us all as did the
personal profiles of the space shuttle
astronauts who deployed and serviced the
telescope and the scientists who
benefited from its data stream not only
that I'd even joined the ranks of your
most trusted as I served dutifully on
your prestigious Advisory Council I came
to recognize them when you're at your
best nothing in this world can inspire
the dreams of a nation the way you can
dreams fueled by
a pipeline of ambitious students eager
to become scientists engineers and
technologists in the service of the
greatest quest there ever was sorry
sorry
[Music]
you have come to represent a fundamental
part of America's identity not only to
itself but to the world
so as we both turn 60 and begin our 61st
trip around the Sun I want you to know
that I feel your pains and share your
joys and I look forward to seeing you
back on the moon but don't stop there
Mars beckons as do destinations beyond
birthday buddy
even if that but even if I have not
always been I am now your humble servant
Neil deGrasse Tyson
you